if you have somebody who habitually
looks for what's wrong and tries to fix
it they're gonna organize their personal
life very differently from someone who
makes who makes ideas of what could be
and pursues those and you know again
people don't necessarily think oh am i
moving away from unpleasantness or I'm
moving towards things that are awesome
to the extent that you can start to
understand your behavior patterns and
where you are get where which behavior
patterns or which thought patterns give
you what you want and which ones get in
the way of what you want there is a
degree to which and I don't believe it's
as malleable as some people believe but
there's a degree to which you can rewire
how you approach certain things so that
you can make up for your natural
deficiencies or if you know where your
strengths are and actually even getting
into the idea of what's a strength and
what's the deficiency is a whole nother
question because something that can be a
strength can also be a weakness it just
depends upon where you're applying it
what you're trying to do but knowing
those things about yourself you can
either partner with people who
compliment you or you can seek to
develop the other strategy you know the
other side of the coin boom what's up
everyone welcome to a simulation I'm
your host Alan Saki on we are at MIT the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology in
the beautiful Cambridge Massachusetts we
are now going to be talking about
turning your big picture into action we
have Steve Robbins joining us on the
show hello hello thank you so much for
coming on the show really appreciate you
for having me here I'm super pumped also
very grateful to Luke saver for
introducing us and I'm so pumped because
stever's background is epic he's a
Renaissance man executive coach author
speaker and veteran of nine startups and
four IPOs he co-developed the
Foundation's module of the Harvard MBA
program you can find Steve Robbins comm
link in the bio also itunes.com for
slash get it done guys his podcast and
you can find get it done guy on Facebook
and Twitter as well all those links are
in the bio stever
let's start things off with our one of
our favorite questions to ask we love
asking people about what their thoughts
are on the direction of our world Oh
I'm afraid I'm a cynic I'm a very happy
cynic but I'm a cynic I think we on many
many fronts are headed in a bad
direction frankly we were doing well the
human race is in many way by many
measurements we have never done so well
as a race we have less violence we have
more health people are living longer
it's certainly in aggregate we have more
prosperity we have fewer people living
in poverty a lot of indicators are
really wonderful
unfortunately I and I figured this out
actually just a couple days ago I tend
to look much less at where we are than
where we're headed and I do this pretty
much everywhere and in terms of the
human race I look at things like how are
we doing with respect to the environment
do we have an economy that is
sustainable are we making progress on
things like human rights which we are at
the moment you know and where do I think
we're going to be ten years from now and
one of my big worries my big concerns is
that some of the biggest problems we
have things like global warming things
like income inequality and and in
particular wealth inequality not
necessarily income inequality although
obviously they're tied I think these
things are reaching a point and in a
direction where they're going to be big
problems and we can predict now that
they're going to be big problems it's
just if we predict it and don't act on
it they will be even bigger problems and
we are we are not acting as hard as we
can you know so unfortunately that's my
you know on the other hand we have some
great at least in America we have some
great social movements you know I think
that we're becoming healthier in many
ways in terms of accepting diversity
more and and so on and so forth so some
of those some of the social trends I
think are positive and I hope they
continue when I hope that we can reverse
a lot of the other ones you're right I
mean global warming is probably my
number one big abou Bugaboo because if
it turns out to be as bad as a lot of
scientists are predicting and if species
extinction continues the way that it's
going we're going to be dead and if
we're dead it doesn't matter how good
everything else is because we're dead
dead is bad yeah you can quote me on
that one there's there's there's there's
a lot there I we
you frequently visit this conversation
of how well things are going across so
many markers at the same time we know
that there is so much old code that
needs to be archived and that we need to
put the new codes in and the Millennials
and Gen Z have the responsibility to to
take it all the burden on their back and
put the action forward and get out of
some of the old archaic ruts that I
talked to them directly for a second
please okay Millennials and Gen Z people
listen very carefully in my parents time
they said oh our children are going to
have to bear the brunt and fix what went
on in my time we're saying oh our
children have to bear the brunt and fix
what's going on etc but why didn't we
why didn't my generation fix all of this
and the answer is that systems lock you
in if you decide oh I want to change the
way the system works understand that
that it's really hard to change a system
from within because for example let's
just use let's just let's say that we
decide that money needs to stop being a
thing and we need to find ways to
distribute resources to people who need
them whether or not they have the money
to pay for them as you are starting that
movement you need to eat and since the
movement hasn't happened yet you need to
work to earn money to eat because
without money you can't eat what happens
is great you go out you get a job you
start earning money and before you know
it you're 40 years old and you have
spent your entire life trying to build a
career and now you possibly have a
family you might have children and now I
mean you can't afford to just give all
that up and go live in a cardboard box
because etc what happens is is when
you're trying to change a system you
actually have to give up the old system
and you don't necessarily have the new
one in place yet and I don't know that
it's possible to change your world
system I'll just give one example then
we can get back to I'll let you drive
again but the one thing is that right
now virtually all of our definitions of
wealth and success are growth measures
right it's oh I'll get a 10%
turn on my investment you want to hear
something insane here's something insane
they say that the the population of
Japan is going to decrease by 30 percent
in the next 30 years or so and they're
saying oh my god this is gonna be an
economic catastrophe forget the economy
for a minute we have a situation where
we have enough infrastructure to feed
and clothe a certain number of people in
30 years we're gonna have that same
amount of infrastructure but we're only
gonna have 2/3 as many people so in a
sane world we would be celebrating we
would be saying look at this we don't
even have to do any extra work and
suddenly everyone will be able to have
50 percent more than they have now if
you do the math it comes out to 50% more
like isn't that awesome and amazing but
the way that our economy is set up where
everything depends upon growth and this
that and the other
we actually are saying this is going to
be a catastrophe that's insane that's
seriously insane but that's the way that
our system works and Gen Z's and
Millennials because I'm still talking to
you you're gonna need to find ways of
breaking that at levels that are so
fundamental you may find yourself asking
questions like like does ownership at a
distance even make sense like right you
know once upon a time people only owned
the stuff they could carry with them and
now we have you know a person like a
Jeff Bezos who can own a hundred and
sixty billion dollars or whatever his
net worth is up to by the time this airs
and in a sustainable society that's a
healthy society does the notion of
ownership include the ownership of some
abstract thing thousands of miles away
because apparently he owns most of Texas
and that's a really important question
that you're gonna have to ask and you're
gonna have to grapple with if the answer
is no how do you overturn the people
like Jeff Bezos who really really care
that they owned all this stuff at a
distance anyway good luck with that
so yeah this this speaks really deeply
to how it can be tough to dig out of
that that rut of old code and the system
that were birthed into is difficult to
augment because we have to abide by
so much of the code in that old system
so one of the keys here is to create a
new mental map create new code that
obsoletes the old code I keep coming
back to this example of whoever whatever
Satoshi Nakamoto is and blockchain
technology just coming in and just
completely flipping over centralized
systems onto their heads and inspiring
people to care more about decentralized
technology about cryptocurrencies about
the potential that that has so we need
young people to decide to make new codes
bring them in that are so powerful that
they just inspire and engage so many
people to obsolete the old systems and
go with the new ones that's so so well
said and we have a lot more to unpack on
even just that subject but let's keep I
could I could jump in because by the way
blockchain still assumes ownership
there's still an entire set of
underlying economic assumptions to the
notion of wanting to avoiding any sort
of currency because currency has been
one of the most amazing inventions of
all of human history it's been
unbelievably powerful
and it's been unbelievably destructive
both and we may have to give up some of
the power if we want to avoid the
destruction and again you know it's
I wish it were my job I'd fix things
there's there's there's quite a bit that
we can also learn from the understanding
of just slowing down and thinking and
not not rushing and just wanting to make
sure that the children that are born
into the world don't have any rotten
roots and within the within the
nutrients of the tree so that they can
blossom fully a lot of the a lot of the
malevolence 'iz and violence's and
issues that we see that happened in the
world today are a direct representation
of our just Rush and urge to want to you
know populate with with people no matter
what kind of an education or nutrient
system that they get at their roots and
also just quickly on the Japan example I
think this is a very profound way of
seeing things that we're so in the old
way of thinking that we can't even see
something like a population
stabilization
we have ownership of like you gave an
example of people that are very wealthy
that owns so many properties that that
they don't even use at times but there's
still people that sleep on the streets
how does that work and then also yeah if
we have the infrastructure in place well
even if the population stabilizes a
slightly declines in a developing world
it's also nice that we don't necessarily
need to be sometimes constructing so
much of property there's so many
interesting points that go off of that
and I also just I really want to hit on
Stevie's journey because you are a very
fascinating multidisciplinary Polymathic
thinker and you're gonna be unpacking
tons of these interesting strategies for
us but I want to know how you got to
where you are today
I'm gonna give you the highlights that
I'm gonna let you delve in I grew up in
many different places my my mother and
father were hippies sort of New Age
hippies and for a while we lived in a
23-foot trailer with seven people kind
of bouncing around the country starting
psychic growth centers I call that my
traveling New Age commune days ah we
settled well my parents got a divorce I
settled with my mother then decided to
move out to live with my father my
father did not however want to have me
living with him so we rented an
apartment for me I was 14 at the time we
went to an apartment for me
right next to his house so his house the
little apartment next to it and then he
moved away and I decided to stay so I
became an emancipated minor put myself
through high school programming
computers went to MIT and got a computer
science undergrad which was very cool
went out into industry worked as a well
went out into industry worked as a
programmer then shifted into working as
a trainer for a software and hardware
company because I figured out that I did
not have social skills and that I did
not have communication skills and I said
I must develop these these seemed to be
important and what better way to do it
than to teach people things so did that
then the company I was working for which
the best product on the market started
to go under and I went to my manager and
I said how is it possible for a company
with a product as good as ours to go
under and she said ah to understand that
you must understand marketing strategy
and I'm like marketing strategy what the
heck is that and she said well actually
what I said was how do I get to
understand that and she said well for
that you need gray hair or an MBA and I
lived walking distance from Harvard
Business School so one day I just
wandered down and said hi guys I want an
MBA and they said ok
much to my extreme surprise so this
little kid from the literally from the
wrong side of the tracks remember those
peoples that your parents warned you
about that was me and my sister we were
the ones who they were warning you about
and I got in and I remember I still
remember to this day holding the
acceptance letter to Harvard Business
School and because my boss had said she
said you can always apply and if you get
in you don't have to go and I remember
sitting there looking at the acceptance
letter thinking she's wrong
like I freaking got into Harvard
freaking Business School there's no way
I can say no to this so did that for a
couple of years when I graduated moved
out to Silicon Valley worked for Intuit
the people who make quicken in
QuickBooks anyone out there if you have
the quicken Visa Card my project after
Intuit my mother came down with colon
cancer and I took care of her for the
last several months of her life that was
a rather taxing experience at the end of
that I had moved back to Boston spent a
year playing and I remember thinking
many times man I have to write down all
the things I did this year this is such
an amazing year forgot to write and even
down so I know I had an amazing year
don't over what doing what then I was
asked back to Harvard Business School to
help them redesign part of the MBA
curriculum and I spent two years doing
that really delving into what are the
skills that make leaders what are the
skills that people need to be able to
think strategically and then furthermore
how do you teach those because a lecture
isn't going to do it so I spent two
years studying everything the human race
knew about human learning theory how
people learn
and how do you learn emotional things
mm-hmm asked me later about the design
of my ethics program the faculty took
one look at it and they were like no it
was like absolutely not no way they're
like lawsuit City and I'm like but
better to do this in the back and then
we can fire MIT where no one will get
hurt they're like no we're gonna talk to
people about ethics we are not going to
do this design so anyway did that for a
couple years then spent a time as the
chief operating officer of a start-up
move from there into organizational
learning consulting and transfer of best
practices so if you have a big company
and you have two units one is doing
really doing stuff well the other one is
and how do you model that and transfer
it then joined another startup then was
dissatisfied with that startup and
through is not particularly interesting
story became an executive coach because
it became apparent by that time that I
naturally sort of everyone around me I
made my mission to help them be more
awesome and be more incredible and you
know develop their skills to the max and
get what they wanted out of life so like
why not do this professionally and had a
coaching practice which I've had for a
long time now which has been broken up
by a few different periods of employment
I was the president of a friend of Mines
company for a little while I also went
back to Babson College and helped with
they were doing a strategy redesign when
then they changed presidents several
years ago and I got involved with that
that was right before the 2008 bubble
burst I also did a three-year journey
here where I tried I hit a certain age
mmm which we don't have to talk about
and I said you know I now have enough
data to help figure out what makes life
amazing because I'm a certain age I went
to Harvard Business School and MIT which
means all of the people who I went to
school with if anyone should have
amazing lives it should be those people
so I just called him all up and I said
where are you in life how did you get
there did you get there the way you
thought you would and what were the key
things and I basically came up with a
list of things that seemed to correlate
to having an amazing life put these into
a TEDx talk gave it a TEDx Mill River in
I think Connecticut they screwed the
video up so unfortunately it
not on the the the TEDx site however I
turned it into an hour-long presentation
and I gave it at Harvard Business School
like eight or nine times to standing
room only
it was very cool it's a great speech and
it is online on my website somewhere I'm
not sure I'm not sure how easy it is to
find but it is there but but I did this
three-year experiment in that three-year
experiment I changed the rules of high
made decisions and I did some stuff that
even today today to this day I'm kind of
like wow that was really cool so I
started a little podcast which became
the number one business podcast on
iTunes for for many months it has since
dropped down in the ratings but I've
been doing it for 11 years now based
upon the podcast I got a book contract
this is gonna be weird based upon the
book contract
I was joking with a friend I for some
reason I just developed this spontaneous
interest in musical theater and I was
talking with a friend as I was getting
ready for my book tour and I said I said
you know I'm really bummed about this
book tour and he said why and I said
because I suddenly want to be doing
musical theater and instead of me going
around talking about my book which is a
book on personal productivity I said
like wouldn't be cool if I had a one-man
musical that was based on my book it was
like the world's first musical that's so
dramatic that people cried but so
informative the people take notes and
and it would all be about personal
productivity and he just kind of looked
at me and he said you do know what I do
for a living don't you and I was like
yeah you're a journalist because I
thought it was a journalist he's like no
I teach musical theater composition and
writing at NYU I was like you do he said
yes
a week later I finally got the courage
to ask him do you want to do this I have
no prior musical theater experience I
have never sung a song in my life I
don't know how to write a script I have
no idea how to write dialogue well
unfortunately it wasn't done in time for
the book launch however you can see the
first five minutes or you can see a five
minute teaser for work less and do more
the zombie musical which is the world's
only musical that is so dramatic that
you might cry we actually tone to that
part down a little bit and so
informative that you'll take notes and
it is about a J's
be a general of a zombie army who's a
human his name is Steve Robbins and he
general stiva Robbins of course and he
went to Harvard Business School and at
Harvard Business School they'd never
invited him to the parties because they
said he was a bad in ba so the all the
other kids would have parties where they
would eat Oreo ice cream cake and they
wouldn't invite him so he decided that
he was gonna get back to them by raising
a zombie army and cornering the world
supply of Oreo ice cream cake so if they
had parties in the future they would
have to invite him that's what the
musical is about I mean as musicals are
write it that's just one of those
standard tropes I mean everyone writes
the zombie general Oreo ice cream cake
musical and and he ends up boy I don't
know how much I don't want to get deeply
into this story but basically basically
things don't go the way he planned and
it becomes both a very human story about
how do we know what we really want and
what do we really want as well as a very
informative story because it teaches you
several productivity tips from my book I
think that is the number the thing I am
proudest of out of everything I've done
in my life was that musical because it
was so far outside anything I had ever
done it changed my image of myself in a
very major way and then since then I I
have went back to executive coaching I
did some development of a workshop based
on the living an extraordinary life
series which ended up not coming to
market for various reasons and then I'm
currently been doing something called
get it done groups which are communities
that help people finish things and
develop new habits and there's also lots
of other stuff somewhere in there there
were six or seven other startups that I
was involved in at various times okay it
all runs together what a story
especially nuts all the way from being a
kid and and traveling with your parents
to the different what was its site it's
well we start a psychic Rossa psychic
growth centers and then living by
yourself as an emancipated child and
then we're gonna Majan how how popular I
was since I had my own apartment and all
of my friends could use it
to bring their dates over I'm just sayin
sure sure sure sure I learned about the
real world
earlier y-yeah yeah yeah I can yeah you
can see that and then so so it's also
interesting that you ended up teaching
yourself out of program computers yeah
and going at MIT and learning that oh
wow I should learn how to talk to people
and I should learn more about humans and
behavior and cognition and all that good
stuff and so then the that whole
transition with with marketing strategy
and how you ended up realizing that you
could kind of you kind of gave a nice
little merger of those two worlds and a
sense of the of the heavy programming
side of things with a business side of
things with Harvard Business School and
you like you made it clear to with
Harvard with Babson with these different
institutions if you're actually able to
put together programs that get people to
understand that a lot of the business
skills the social-emotional skills that
we learn are through experiential
learning a lot of entrepreneurship is
through experiential learning so how do
you make curriculum that takes people
out of textbooks and into eye-to-eye
contact into relationships into the nuts
and bolts of that type of stuff
and all the way to the five hundred and
fifty episodes that you've done get it
done guy and kid a dumb guy and just the
seven and nine minutes that you have to
synthesize of how to best be be
productive be able to put things
together that you want to get done
overcome fear all this type of stuff is
just so critical and it's not just like
the sub part of our lives this is
immediately applicable to every single
part of our lives
yes family our friends our co-workers
our our customers and in just every the
way we vibe even in the general public
all these things come together they
coalesce this is not just something
about how to use a certain tool on a
computer no no definitely in fact one of
the things that I feel fairly strongly
about
is is right now you know the there's an
app for that concept there's not
actually an app for human relationships
no matter how much people want them to
be I find I find it hilarious that like
all these dating apps what do you enter
you enter things like what's your hair
color how tall are you how much do you
weigh what it may be what are your
measurements you know whatever why do
you enter those because engineers the
least capable people in the world of
forming relationships generally speaking
do understand how to do numerical
comparisons those are very easy to do in
code so of course they have you fill out
a profile that's basically all the stuff
that's easy for them to program however
we actually know a lot a whole lot about
what makes people bond what makes people
fall in love what is what goes for a
compatible relationship and let me tell
you it's not hair color it's not how
high it's not how tall someone is it's
not what their measurements are it's all
kinds of other things none of which any
of the apps deal with except maybe I
mean there's like some mass comm that
does show ya the psychometric profiles
being able to know someone better than
the spouse of that person knows them
based on their Facebook likes this type
of stuff is nuts building out their
psychometric profiles let's go ahead
let's go ahead and start diving deeper
into all of this so your fascination
with how people think how people reach
their full potential and actually
realize that by working with with you
that they that they see themselves
actually oh I used to not like to try
and call people to build a customer
relationship management funnel oh all of
a sudden 12 weeks later oh I love
calling people I love building out this
funnel it's like hold up hold up just
three months ago you hated this stuff
these types of realizations are actually
really important for us to slow down and
realize yeah I've grown quite a bit if
you look at any of the episodes from you
know a year and a half ago it was gobbly
goop you know and now yeah now it's
gotten a little better it's like
kindergarten interviewing class like I
got a little better it says only so it's
how good to slow down and reflect on
that but yeah so this is
everything from the organizational level
to the people level this is another
critical thing that you help all the way
from executive ceos all the way to other
people like in just their normal
everyday relations to me it's all tied
together because a human so so people
and it's this is one of the things that
always amazed me about organizational a
lot of the stuff in the organizational
development and organizational change
literature is people treat the
organization as if it is somehow
separate and divorced from the people
it's not I mean people want to believe
it is but and and it and in terms of
performance it's sort of isn't but if
you want to change an organization what
it means to change an organization is it
means there are human beings inside that
organization who are going to have to
behave differently when they come into
work tomorrow
that's what it means to change an
organization it means you have to change
the components and it's made up of
people so to me there's a very clear
link between organizational process and
big picture and how does an organization
get where it wants to go and the micro
things about people let me give you a
specific example let's say that you have
someone who's running a big company and
human beings have a tendency and I'm
gonna say tendency because it differs
per person and it differs according to
context but some people are highly
motivated towards a grand vision other
people are highly motivated to fix
things that are broken and again it's
contextual in one context you may be one
in one context you may be another
let's say you have a CEO who is highly
motivated to fix things that are broken
what they're going to ask for the kind
of information they're gonna collect is
how many errors are we producing what's
going wrong what you know what are the
solutions you have to fix what's going
wrong but their whole orientation is
gonna be around finding errors and
fixing them which means they're gonna
hire people who can find errors and fix
them and which means their Direction is
going to largely be one of finding and
fixing other side of the coin is you can
have someone who's very much a visionary
who says oh there's this giant castle in
the air let's go there and everyone says
oh we can't go there it's in the air and
they say that doesn't matter build a
ladder they're like you can't build a
ladder that tall and they go do
anyway and sometimes everyone crashes
and burns and sometimes they make it
there and and which of those two people
you have heading up your organization is
going to determine who you hire how you
organize them what things you measure
what things you manage what do you even
consider a threat in the marketplace and
what do you not consider a threat and
what I've found in startups at least and
I suspect it's similar in big companies
although you know maybe less so is most
well most of the CEOs I have direct
experience with they tend to build an
organization which as an organization is
a psychological mirror of them as a
person and if they are good at at
bringing in diverse points of view and
hearing bad news and fixing things and
also it at being a visionary or whatever
you can build an organization that's
well balanced like that even if they're
not like that if they understand the
importance of that they'll assemble a
team that has all those perspectives and
they will you know kind of allow it to
do the things that is not in their
normal personal style but so that's
organizations and individuals and within
individuals you actually have the same
kind of thing if you have somebody who
habitually looks for what's wrong and
tries to fix it they're gonna organize
their personal life very differently
from someone who makes who makes ideas
of what could be and pursues those and
you know again people don't necessarily
think oh am i moving away from
unpleasantness or I'm moving towards
things that are awesome or you know
choose your favorite adjective you've
maybe you know I always wanted to be
enlightened I've solved for that one I
don't want to be enlightened anymore -
boring um not really but but if you if
you to the extent that you can start to
understand your behavior patterns and
where you are get where which behavior
patterns are which thought patterns give
you what you want and which ones get in
the way of what you want there is a
degree to which and I don't believe it's
as malleable as some people believe but
there's a degree to which you can rewire
how you approach certain things so that
you can make up for your natural
deficiencies or if you know where your
strengths are and actually even getting
into the idea of what's a strengths and
what's the deficiency is a whole another
question because something that can be a
strength can also be a weakness it just
depends upon where you're applying it
what you're trying to do but knowing
those things about yourself you can
either partner with people who
compliment you
or you can seek to develop the other
strategy you know the other side of the
coin so I always thought that I was kind
of a visionary
I'm not when I look empirically at my
life not a visionary I care a lot about
the future I'm a futurist but I am much
better at projecting trends than I am at
coming up with a whole new vision of
something that doesn't exist and saying
let's strive for that the thing that
motivates me is fixing problems so
interestingly enough a lot you know most
of my get-it-done Caiaphas's 550
episodes all of those episodes are how
do I solve problem X because that's my
skill set that's the way that my brain
thinks and knowing this is really
important for me to have people around
who say hey we're gonna build this
wonderful tower because then I can say
oh well we're not there yet
the problem is we're not at the tower
yet and therefore my brain just kicks
into high gear and says well we have a
problem we must fix the problem the
problem is we're out of the tower we
need to build a really tall ladder so I
can still get there I can get to the
tower but my brain gets to the tower by
noticing that we're not there and fixing
that problem quote-unquote whereas
someone else's brain might get to the
tower by looking at the tower and going
wow I really want to be in the tower and
they're being motivated as they pull
towards something positive and you know
both of those thinking styles have
different pros and different cons you
know I think I'd be happier if I were
the other kind I think you know because
I'm always dissatisfied with the status
quo but in both scenarios what's key is
to know what the first second third
fourth fifth 10th 20th steps are these
milestones of building the ladder to get
to a vision whether it's solving a
problem we're living in a great world
that has that update it's just actually
executing is worth so much more in the
world ideas are everywhere every idea
has to turn into action or else what's
it good for frankly yeah and then on a
on a personal level - there's so many
skill sets that need to be better
understood with psychology and
behavioral analysis how our brains work
the way that we socially and emotionally
relate to each other how we build a
rapport with each other and doing things
like neuro-linguistic programming NLP
this is fascinating stuff super that's
oh yeah Wow you walk us through all of
these unique ways that we engage with
each other on a human-animal basis ah
that's a pretty tall order I'm going to
talk about NLP we're don't me to talk
like more generally and systemically
because yeah give us general
systemically and then boil it into yes'm
NOP - yeah okay so from what I've been
able to tell of the way human beings
behave is we first of all were animals
and we behave like animals and I woke up
one day and just suddenly started seeing
it every I read a book on primate
behavior and I was like oh no this
explains far too much like and we're at
we are social animals and we are animals
who who have a lot of our brain devoted
to connecting with and being part of a
social tribe because at least according
to the book sapiens which I'm about
halfway through right now the thing that
made Homo Sapien sapien a successful a
successful animal and now at the top of
the food chain was our ability to
organize in groups that is our survival
advantage it's not an individual
survival advantage it's a collective
survival advantage which by the way and
I we didn't even talk about politics as
one of the things that we we're gonna
talk about today so I'll just say one
sentence which is one of the trends I
think is incredibly dangerous right now
is in many different places we are
driving towards a very individualistic
mindset you know like like in the gig
economy everyone is expected to both do
whatever their gig is but also market
themselves and also have a personal
brand and get their name out there and
all this thought leadership and all this
other BS the power that the corporations
have a lot of problems but the power of
a corporation the reason that we have
this globe spanning economy and iPhones
and you know and delicious foods that
you used to not ever be able to get
because there was no way to get them
from here to there the reason we have
that is because we are much more
powerful together than individually and
we're like deliberately dismantling that
it is I think it's just bizarre
you know people
let's say oh well now you have to be
good at all these things I'm like no I
don't want Rembrandt to spend his time
building a website and trying to market
himself and establish a personal brand
by writing thought pieces I want
Rembrandt painting that's that's the
contribution Rembrandt can make to the
world so I like the idea of a world on
which Rembrandt can spend all of his
time painting because that's the thing
that he can do that no one else can do
and like I said we're kind of going in
opposite direction and we're doing that
politically as well where we have the
whole sort of neoliberal philosophy
which is well you know if if you're not
rich or whatever it's cuz you're a bad
person as opposed to having this
understanding that maybe but maybe it's
also that there are systemic effects
that the roots have certain malnourished
mints and this is as you were just
explaining the code here is that it is
different for the seeds their fruits
that they actualize into the world it's
not putting everyone in the same need to
develop your personal brand need to
build a website you need to have a CRM
with a certain amount of people and a
certain amount of revenue and a certain
picket fence in a certain car that's
gonna get past that and it's also a DNA
that's not just about the individuals
but it's about our communities it's
about the culture as we live in you know
what I one day I was at a business
networking meeting there were 14 of us
all men and as we were getting up to go
I looked around and I suddenly realized
every single person in that room was
wearing a powder blue button-down shirt
and khakis and I burst out laughing and
they said what's so funny and I said do
you notice that we're all dressed
identically and we went downstairs and
stood on the sidewalk and looked around
to downtown Boston and basically every
guy who came within who we who he could
see who walked down any of the streets
they were all wearing a powder blue
shirt and khakis and I look at this and
I go we live in the richest most
successful society in all of human
history in terms of our material
standard of living in terms of the
options that are available in terms of
the technology we have and we use it to
produce a level of conformity and
uninteresting this in our lives in our
clothes like it's it's really kind of
amazing how how completely bland we've
our existence and I we this was really
this really got got pounded home to me
three years ago when I went to Burning
Man for the first time and I looked
around and I was like oh right it
doesn't have to be that way there are
actually all kinds of dimensions of
interestingness if we can just kind of
get out of our little shell of believing
like one of my favorites is is you know
when people say well just give you a
real example I was on Facebook one day
and there was a Harvard Business School
alumni meeting that was gonna go on and
I posted two thing to Facebook saying
I'm thinking of wearing jeans and a
t-shirt to the Alumni meeting tonight
should I do that or not and people are
like oh my god if you don't wear a suit
people will never take you seriously
they'll never do business with you
you'll destroy your Apple love all this
stuff and I was reading this I was going
people are describing life destroying
consequences because I choose to wear
one piece of fabric rather than another
one you know what I wore jeans and a
t-shirt to that meeting I was the only
one who wasn't in a suit no one cared
the people who normally talked to me
talk to me the people who ignored me
continued to ignore me the people who
didn't hire me continued not to hire me
the world did not end and I was like how
is it possible that we have created a
world in which wearing a t-shirt instead
of a button-down shirt has any
consequence at all much less terrorizes
all of these people who are you know and
now keep in mind I was raised in a
traveling new-age commune you know
wearing loincloths so I'm not exactly a
suit kind of guy these are the new codes
though again is being able to obsolete
the old code see the new codes put it
into the old system the new codes this
is so critical King to take us into more
on the social emotional intelligence
that NLP yep yeah yeah all right so I
figured out when I was I figured out
actually in college that I didn't really
have great social skills so I didn't
have any friends right other side of the
tracks all that stuff so I read so I
took every psychology course offered at
MIT thinking oh because I was a little
nerd right I'm like oh well you know
they must surely know how to make
friends
maybe there's a course on it so I took
psychopharmacology and I took this
overview course where you learn about
Jungian therapy and object relationship
and Freudianism
and transactional analysis and you know
all these different things
and I had one very simple criterion
which is that I wanted to be able to use
what I learned to make friends with this
person who we had established we wanted
to be friends but for some reason it
just we just didn't click but we knew we
kind of both wanted to be friends none
of it worked none of it gave me anything
useful me and then I read this book on
neuro linguistic programming mm-hmm and
I thought this sounds so bizarre I
couldn't think this could never really
work and then I took a class in it a
weekend workshop and it taught just
enough of it cuz it's taught
experientially it's not taught and you
don't lecture you actually do exercises
and I learned enough of it and I went
back to school and I was able to sit
down with that person and talk to him
and what I was using was a technique
called predicate matching which is a
fancy way of saying if someone uses
visual words use visual words back if
someone uses auditory words like they
say oh that sounds like a good idea
use use auditory words back and if they
use feeling words they say wow I having
in trouble getting a grip on this use
feeling words back and say wow that's a
really hard problem we just speed up to
scratch the surface of it and that was
enough once I realized that I was
mismatching the person I was talking to
I just switched into his sensory
modality a boom
we became friends and I was like oh this
actually works unlike all of the other
stuff that you know that I that I had
learned about and that was the beginning
of my foray into NLP and I started
training in it NLP is rooted in hypnosis
and by NLP I mean neural endlessly
programming not natural language
processing it's rooted in the study of
the hypnotist named Milton Erickson MD
who I think is I don't know if he's
widely considered but certainly
certainly he's considered to be one of
the best hypnotist of all time if not
the best and I gradually learned this I
kept taking classes because I kept
learning stuff I could really use right
like when you take a class on how to how
to change a belief well that's actually
useful as long as you take the time to
notice which beliefs you have that are
dysfunctional and if you realize wow
I've been sitting here believing that
that that I'm bad at math I think this
is actually a true story I I met
somebody who clearly thought like a
mathematician but he was horrible at
math because he believed he was bad at
it and I did the NLP belief change with
him and all of a sudden you could do
math like he was just like boom
and what did that look like the belief
change oh I don't wanna go into the I
mean it it sometimes we sit down with
scientists or entrepreneurs usually not
entrepreneurs sometimes we sit down with
scientists entrepreneurs typically have
confidence because they have to be
willing to to be called insane or
pursuing what they're doing in a
marketplace scientists sometimes aim to
become communicators at the edge from
the edge of their field and they
sometimes lack that that confidence and
so I would say more than sometimes yeah
and we desperately need them to become
communicators and get the objective
reality down to more people yeah well as
also actually I would suggest it's not
just about objective reality it's about
understanding if you want people to
change their behavior facts don't do it
and this is one of the things I find
hilarious about scientists there's a lot
of science there's a lot of research
showing that facts don't change people's
minds and so scientists who aren't
interested in that particular fact
because scientists want to believe that
facts change people's minds scientists
demonstrate the fact that facts don't
change people's minds by refusing them
use anything except facts to try to
change people's minds and unlike dudes
do you understand
you are literally demonstrating that
facts don't change people's minds
because you scientists are ignoring
scientific facts like but in any event
that's one of my pet peeves because I
think that with respect to global
warming for example I think scientists
have done an unbelievably bad job of
communicating this because they are so
concerned with saying well you know
there is a ninety eight point three
eight seven two percent chance that this
could be caused by anthropological
excuse me by anthropological global
warning warming with a 70 to 80 percent
confidence interval and maybe there is a
range of outcomes which might include
bad things happening forty five years
from now and I'm like wow I feel so
persuaded I'm like dudes look in the
camera and say we're going to die Miami
is going to be underwater the
Chane will collapse you will go to the
grocery store and these shelves will be
empty except for the zombies which will
be singing songs about personal
productivity has that your brains yeah I
mean scientists don't know how to
communicate but to get to the question
about fear let me tell you one of the
basic tenants of NLP and by the way NLP
is not is considered a pseudoscience let
me be very clear about that
the fact that I can use it to produce
reproducible results does not mean the
science has embraced it interestingly
enough my criterion is the results piece
I think neuro linguistic programming is
going to benefit greatly from our
ability to create better neuroscience
tools and then be able to literally map
neural activity and be able to show redo
reproducibility and then it is blatantly
obvious that it is actually about seven
or eight years ago I read this article
in Technology Review mi t--'s science
magazine that was talking about memory
formation the latest theories of memory
formation and one of them one of the
theories is that when you remember
something you can actually modify it
whilst in short-term memory and the
modifications get written back to
long-term memory and and the article
ends with this thing saying you know the
authors theorized that perhaps someday
this could be used for the treatment of
trauma in 1978 the guys who created NLP
put out a book called frogs into princes
in which they had a in which they have a
technique called the fast phobia cure or
maybe it's the trauma care I forget
which at this point it's called visual
kinesthetic sociation is is the other
name they use for it because it involves
doing some fancy stuff with visual and
kinesthetic stuff in your brain and it
works now we've never known why it
worked but as soon as I read that
article about how memory is from like oh
this is the technique that
operationalizes us the problem is the
scientists who figured out how memory
works have never seen the technique and
the people who develop the technique the
people in NLP knew nothing about the
science they weren't looking at the
underlying science they were just saying
what seems to work and they kind of
figured it out by trial and error so
I've made a bunch of these connections
I'm not holding my breath for the rest
of the world to make them but in the NLP
model of how people think and then and
there are other psychological models too
it's pretty much it
accepted that people you have thoughts
and in Iraq to the thoughts as if
they're real so my friend had the
thought I'm bad at math and as a result
he didn't even try to do math because he
knew he was bad at it he already had
that belief your belief takes a certain
form in your brain it's either pictures
that you're making or a voice where
you're talking to yourself so maybe he
actually was saying to himself I'm bad
at math maybe he was making a picture of
of that math test that he got back in
third grade with a big red X on it but
he had some mental thing going on that
was that was the representation he used
to know that he was bad at math the NLP
belief change is first you have to
understand and discover what that
person's representation is and a lot of
times people aren't aware of what the
representation is because it comes and
goes so quickly you're not you're not
aware of what your beliefs are
constructive but when you're working
with someone doing an LP they can
actually say stop what do you what are
you picturing right this instant those
oh I see this picture of my second grade
math test with a big red X through it
all right wonder why that could have
popped up when we were talking about
being bad at math coincidence probably
not and so then there are techniques and
NLP for actually changing that image
because if you're dealing with trustful
people's and know they're one of those
things that you it's very important to
get people to open up about their
vulnerability and it should use the word
vulnerable people but sometimes people
will lie blatantly to not show their
vulnerability and so rather than saying
that I'm getting extremely furious and
angry right now wait wait why are you
feeling that way oh well you know it's
probably because I was beaten by my
parents right at the rather it turns
into it because you're an idiot that's
why I'm behaving this way and so that's
it's it's a it's really difficulty for
even people to reflect back and even
realize that something with between the
ages of 0 and 6 or something could have
potentially led them to and they may not
even be aware of it I mean yeah they may
genuinely be unaware of it the
vulnerability thing is interesting I
seem to have no boundaries there which
is kind of bizarre you know it
let's just say this can cause some
problems in my relationship because you
know people can ask me what what
apparently are very personal questions I
don't parse them that way when you know
somebody says if someone says to me you
know why are you so angry if I actually
will stop and think about it I go oh you
know probably because my parents used to
beat me and this is like reminding me of
that situation so I think I'm kind of
thinking that you're beating me up you
know or whatever like yeah that's that's
that's that's one of the ways which I
would at that point have to literally
pause everything and literally talk to
you about that and and try and you know
be there with you for that and for that
experience versus it's so weird that
people think that saying when they say
something that I'm feeling miserable
right now and then they're like okay and
then that that that that's it also the
vulnerability or just sheer openness on
things like I I don't I don't subscribe
to conformist mentality so if I do see
everyone wearing a suit I'm gonna wear
my DNA tree shirt right now and if I do
see that people treat sex as a taboo
subject I'm gonna walk in there and be
like why do heterosexual males and not
know how to perform oral sex on women
properly right and so and so these will
literally be the things that I will
breach conversations with purposefully
because I want to shatter the taboo I
want to get there and so some people
will say Alan that's not okay for the
for the for the boardroom you know
that's not okay for the for the suite
c-level suite or whatever but those are
some times the place is the United
Nations to be able to dose up on the
conversations like that would open
people say well well well look I mean if
you want to say that's not the place
where the board review no that's not a
thing for the boardroom apparently it is
if you take a look at the me to movement
apparently it's been going on to be
people don't talk about it there but
apparently there's a lot of a lot of not
good stuff that happens along those
dimensions and that's actually one of
the I mean you know you mentioned the
sex thing and I've always found a
things fascinating and the first one
came to me during Harvard Business
School when I was there as a student
which is we learned about the
entertainment industry write about
movies and the entertainment industry's
a big industry its billions and billions
of dollars every year and at one point
one of the professor's commented that
the adult entertainment industry was
much larger than this traditional
entertainment industry and I'm like so
how come we have 45 cases on Hollywood
and we have none on the porn industry
now you know well no well that's a
tablet why wait why does it have a word
a business school that is a business
that represents a significant fraction
of the economy and by the way drives
most technological adoption like don't
you think we should be studying that
like doesn't you know shouldn't we be
talking about it maybe we should be
putting like pictures of sex on our
washing machines or something like like
it struck me as amazing that this this
taboo would override the purpose of the
school which is to under like the
reality is it's an industry yes and we
probably should study it because if they
have something to teach us very
interesting yeah you know when you go
outside and look around within a couple
of blocks at least in a in a big city
you can find a place to get food
prepared according to your
specifications of any ethnicity at
certain levels of health you know of
health standards and so on and so forth
we can do that with food we don't do
that with sex we don't even talk about
that we don't do that with intimacy we
don't do that with our emotional needs
no thermal needs there's all of these
human needs that we have and you know
yeah we've we've got food and water down
pretty well and also clothing and
shelter we've got those for but there's
this entire panoply of interpersonal
needs that we have of needs for
validation needs to feel good about what
we're doing and you know and I have a
great question for this for that for
this segment specifically so then how
would one be able to apply something
like a neuro linguistic programming in
order for them to be able to talk to
their boss about how they feel at work
how to talk to their spouse or their
partner about how they feel in their
relationship talk to their parent about
something so I'm not gonna go I'm not
gonna go with NLP because
so just just to give you a little bit of
context I am now so I am now have taken
some form of training in 45 different
schools of personal change okay so I
like it so NLP is one school of personal
change yes so out of all of the
executive coaching there's forty
five-plus of the schools of personal
change so teach us about how which
schools of personal change would you
apply to these scenarios it's called the
work of byron katie and it's marketed
primarily as spirituality it's i mean
maybe it's spirituality I don't know I'm
not a particularly spiritual person it
is definitely the most powerful
psychological technique I've ever
encountered and again I judge these by
whether I can produce consistent
repeated results with it and the work of
Byron KD is you identify the the
internal dialogue and the things that
you say to yourself and the beliefs that
you have that are driving your behavior
so let's say you're afraid to be
vulnerable with your boss first thing
you would do is you'd say why am i
afraid mm-hmm
what are the real what am i afraid will
happen and you would write down on a
piece of paper
I am afraid if I am vulnerable with my
boss I will get fired whatever whatever
whatever remember and by the way get it
done by episode number 15 is the one I
actually interviewed Byron Katie in that
episode and she did a role play with me
but it's you write down all these
statements so if I'm vulnerable with my
boss I'll get fired
if I'm vulnerable if I'm vulnerable with
my boss I'll never get promoted if I'm
vulnerable with my boss they'll yell at
me whatever these are and and you get
you you write down the ones like you
really identify the things you're really
feeling
don't don't whitewash it because if you
you need to get the the actual thoughts
that are causing you the distress then
you do her process which is called the
work and if you're interested you can go
to the work calm and somewhere on that
site there's a reaction if you go to
Steve or dot me so Steve or me Steve or
dot me forward slash the work that will
redirect you to the page on her site
that has all of her free downloadable
resources you can teach yourself to do
it the trick is not the trick is not
learning the technique the trick is
actually sitting down and doing it and
it's not necessarily easy being into the
depths of your own psyche and you have
to be honest with yourself yes so like
one of the questions you asked so let's
say that let's say that the thought that
I
have is if I'm vulnerable with my boss
I'll get fired
one of the things you look at is you say
when I believe that how do I behave so
what are the things that I do as a
result of that and that's one of the
places that you have to be genuinely
honest so well when I believe that if
I'm vulnerable with my boss I'll get
fired I lie I say things that I think
will make me look good
even though I know they're not true I
tried to belittle people around me even
if they did good contributions because I
want to build myself up and build them
down
I feel superior to people after doing
that like you actually go through all of
those things that you would never want
to admit about yourself and you don't
have to read them to anyone else but you
have to you have to admit them to
yourself for this technique to work and
then you you go through I mean that's
one of one of the steps just like four
or five different steps of four or five
steps to the technique but I have I've
used it extensively several thousand
times I've actually kept track of my own
inner work that I've done and I have
found that if you take the time to do it
and it can take a while like if you're
afraid to talk to your boss if you're
vulnerable with your boss you might have
fifteen or twenty beliefs that are
related to that that might take you take
you a couple of hours at night to go
through however you take the time to go
through them and in my experience the
next time you think if I'm vulnerable
with my boss I'll get fired instead of
having a horrible fear reaction you'll
think huh I wonder if that's actually
true can I find some evidence for
against so that I make a wise decision
but if I decide to be vulnerable with my
boss I'll just go do it using your
you're titrating a honest conversation
with yourself about the deepest parts of
your own psyche yes that's a great way
to put it even for something that for me
has been really tough to be able to work
with some of the mentors that have been
helping me and identifying myself as
greedy and I'm just like yeah actually I
have been acting that way and
prioritizing my own desires when I'm
attending your organizational events I'm
trying to run in there like a kid and
gather all of the cool
of the powerful nodes instead of
representing someone that is trying to
be selfless that is trying to to
prioritize the needs of other people
first of a higher cause than myself
so you have type a stuff yes and there
may be a belief under there that being
greedy is bad so if I were doing the
work
I would not only do the work on I'm not
greedy because probably what your thing
is I'm not greedy I'm not greedy I'm not
greedy so I would do the work on I'm not
greedy but I would also do the work on
being greedy as bad and that won't make
you they won't necessarily make you
believe being greedy is good but what it
will do is it will remove enough of the
charge that you can really sit down and
think well is it bad and but the answer
you'll probably come to is in some
context yes in other contexts no and you
know and so I want to pick and choose
where I'm greedy and how I'm greedy and
what I'm greedy about you know I mean
you know and even what it means to be
greedy yeah yeah that's that's all
nuance I think that some sort of a
self-actualization and transcendence it
kind of hits all of those things because
then it's just a state of flow of just
having the new code that you're trying
to augment civilization with just just
channel through you and not on behalf of
you so that you can achieve some sort of
a status blah blah you know you know and
and I'll say keep in mind number one
you're still living in a you're still
living in a system where status matters
and you know if you want to make the
better code update status helps you push
out those code updates these this is
where the nuance really helps and I I do
agree with so by the way actually
so speaking of status hopes what here's
one of my pet peeves and I have a lot of
but one of my pet peeves is freaking
billionaires all right now maybe not on
the way people think because I have
heard Bill Gates and Warren Buffett both
say ah in common equity it's so horrible
that it's happening how can we fix this
how can society fix income inequity now
both Bill Gates Melinda Gates have given
interviews that I've read I haven't
heard them but I've read two interviews
with both of them where they were asked
do you think we need systemic change
and both of them said no and this was
almost like an onion headline right man
and woman who have benefited from
current system more than seven billion
nine hundred million nine hundred ninety
nine thousand nine hundred ninety nine
other people think current system is
working just fine
so to begin with the fact that they said
no tells us nothing except they're
they're really benefited for the current
system warren buffett says oh income
inequality this should be fixed gee now
this is where we go from the
organizational and the societal
perspective down to individual behavior
when this is what we were talking about
before about how we have systems that
are made of other systems it's very easy
to use this broad word like income
inequality and an NLP that's something
we call a nominalization which is we're
taking something that's a concept and
treating it like a noun but it's not a
noun it's a it's just an abstract idea
so in NLP what we're taught is when you
hear a nominalization it may be useful
to say what specifically does this mean
so income inequality what specifically
is income inequality right it's like oh
well some people have paid more than
others so then you can say really how
specifically because that's another NLP
question is you say how specifically are
some people paid more than others here's
the answer someone decides to set their
salary to a certain rate that's the
answer who decides that managers HR
departments the owner of the company
that would be Bill Gates Warren Buffett
so when I hear them complaining about
income inequality I'm like Warren dude
you're the second richest man in the
world maybe the third at this point I
don't know we I don't know exactly where
he is
pick up the frickin phone I know you
have one pick up the phone call your 14
operating companies that collectively
employ 300 or 600,000 people and say
give everyone a raise like you're
actually the problem you are the person
in the system who can make that happen
and you don't do it why because
Bill Gates believes the system works
fine so the idea of examining who in
this system is behaving incorrectly
doesn't occur to him Warren Buffett
believes the system works fine so then
potentially one of the solutions is to
have a deep it's a deeper spiritual
understanding of the oneness in the
unity that way it doesn't feel like
there's actually a some sort of a
top-down governmental pressure or a
bottom-up grassroots revolution but just
a really deep reflection on spiritual
actualization and transcendence that
says hey we have 1500 billionaires maybe
if we all just realize that we've
benefited so greatly for the system
let's figure out how to raise the pay of
all the employees that we it's nice the
other thing is it's not even figure out
how we know how we know how we just pick
up the phone and we say give everyone a
raise we also need to run a simulation
of what it's like to increase the amount
of pay for all the people because I'm
just I'm trying to under because we used
to have a living wage like to me this
makes sense that that the just the sheer
amount of you know out of out of the
total amount of money that the company
is is taking as profit if that out of
that total amount of profit if the
company is choosing to pay its couple
owners of the company the most amount of
that profit and even potentially an
egregious amount of that profit compared
to the employees compared to the other
staff at the organization compared to
redistributing it to its community that
it resides in compared to taking on some
of the challenges around the world to
some of the extra profit buying a fifth
boat or fifth house etc so these sorts
of ways of analyzing what is actually
happening to that profit and doing
things like okay if I eliminate two of
the boats
I have three boats instead of five I can
take that additional money and
distribute $1,000 per month
each to the to the 10,000 people that I
employ okay so that type of math makes
sense right so we want to follow math
like that because it kind of makes sense
and then what we see simulated out is
that I continue making enough money to
buy three boats and stuff instead of
five the people that are making $1,000
more per month are able to live
healthier happier more effectively in
their communities with their children
get better education since type of stuff
the overall quality of health goes up so
so it does seem to definitely make sense
it's just that we we get all weirded out
by the grassroots political revolution
or the top-down governmental pressure it
has it just really does we kind of with
the root systems if we could have just
donned it to be a little bit more of a
spiritual realization we probably
wouldn't even necessarily have well if
it's if it's yeah I mean if people so I
find this notion that that the simple
fact that someone owns the stock in a
company entitles them to everything
produced by all the people who do the
work like like I'm willing to say sure
people you know Bill Gates should profit
tremendously from creating Microsoft
that's reasonable like I have no problem
with that
even though venture capitalists this to
put up the funding for the organization
to scale and whatnot it still requires
the hundreds of thousands of employees
and the hunt and the thousands to tens
of us the hundred thousands of customers
around the world so let's right unless
let's look at the actual math I did this
math recently Bill Gates his net worth
is about ninety billion dollars the
median income for a family of four in
America is about sixty thousand dollars
do the division and you will discover
that Bill Gates has enough money to
support a median family of four in
America for a million years or more now
that's ten times as long as our species
has existed
it's really hard for me to come up with
any philosophical system of economic
justice or wealth distribution that says
one man should then one man has somehow
contributed as much as a family of four
would contribute in a million years like
sorry that you know that to me that is
so far out of whack and again you know
that doesn't mean capitalism is bad by
the way capitalism has done some amazing
things and does two amazing things but
but one of the things that doesn't do
well is distribute the spoils of
capitalism so basically I'm actually a
fan of capitalism for the kinds of
problems that capitalism solves but one
of the things that doesn't solve very
well is wealth distribution not in the
absence of certain types of government
regulation or just a certain moral code
and this is one of the things that I
love about Burning Man
because Burning Man has something of a
different ethos and it's a gift economy
which I think is much closer to how
people actually evolved and it spending
time there really makes you realize that
this is that there is a different way of
doing things whether it could be scaled
up to the size of the world don't know
possibly not but it at least opens up
the mind enough to go you know what we
have alternatives yet that's so critical
that's that new code and being able to
have a little simulation of that new
code at Burning Man and all these
different little mini burns that happen
around the world is critical for mind
expansion I wanna I want to get us into
some of these some of these ideas around
be human behavior cognition around
social emotional not intelligence as
well as even to the way that we've need
to update some of the old code we've
been updating code with technology
technology has been this thing that we
think comes in and just does everything
well all the time then people said no no
it's double-edged double-edged even
though it's always been double-edged
fire killing fire cooking and providing
light right there's always this
double-edged now we've I think finally
awakened to how we are using technology
in ways that are completely potential
we can annihilate the entire planet
mutual assured destruction rampant
synthetic biology or super intelligence
that is not aligned with the goals of
humanity so finally we've learned that
we have to test technology so I want you
two to teach about how you teach people
that you work with about how to test the
technology because sometimes we confuse
highjacking with productivity oh we sure
do
we sure did people the most common thing
people say is you know what's the app I
can download for X and the answer is
maybe there's not an app so let me give
a couple specific examples and I'll talk
about what I recommend people do so one
I love the fact that people prefer to
send email to to talking on the phone
because last time I checked I've never
met a person who could type faster than
they talked talking on the if you want
to be productive pick up the frickin
telephone and call someone now if people
say oh but then we talk for 45 minutes
locate your problem is you don't know
how to have a brief phone call the
problem is not that email is a better
medium email is a great medium for in
for certain kinds of information where
people need to see a document or they
need to have a record of something but
if what you want to have is a
conversation email in fact anything that
requires typing sucks
I can type 120 words a minute and it
still sucks because I can talk 300 words
a minute so in terms of actual
productivity for example that's a big
one now most people are afraid of
talking on the phone these days and what
anyone under 30 does not remember is
there was a time when the only way you
had to communicate was by phone there
were not Internet's there were not cell
phones so a truck driver would stop at
rest stops and actually call in to say
here's where I am and that's how they
would track their progress everyone used
phones all the time and this notion of
oh I have phone anxiety no you didn't
because if you had phone anxiety you you
died because you couldn't perform the
basic tasks of daily living and now that
we have all these other things the the
problem with a lot of these technologies
is they're crutches you now don't have
to deal with learning how to respond in
real-time to another human being because
you can type
and edit and not have to deal with their
response if you don't like it you can
just delete the message without reading
it or you could I mean this these are
these are actually bad things because
well they're bad things in the hands of
people who don't have the social skills
developed and people under people under
25 now don't even know that there are
social skills to be developed because
they've grown up doing this kind of
thing I mean if I have I've had I've
worked closely with some people who were
like like who currently like in their
early really early 20s like 21 22 and
it's amazing they they've never lived in
a world where this wasn't the bulk of a
lot of their social communication and
they're not functional human beings I
hate to say that if you're that age
range get a life
put your phone down for a year learn how
to deal with other people I had to do
that I did that at the age of 20 because
I didn't have social skills and it was
not easy but boy is it worth it because
whether we like it or not our brains are
hard-wired to be social they're
hardwired to respond to other people in
a way that an app just can't can't do
and maybe you know the funny part is
people say oh well we'll have virtual
reality it'll be just like someone
standing there I'm like we already have
regular reality we have infinite
resolution every color you can see it's
available just put your freaking phone
down and look around there it is you now
have real reality and there's a real
live person right there respond to them
let's give these examples of the book
versus the e-book oh god yes so there's
already there's already some bunch of
research on this you remember things
better if you read them on a paper book
now they don't know for sure why but the
current theory is that with a paper book
you're not just remembering the content
that you read you remembering where on
the page the content was if you're
holding the book open like this you're
remembering oh this was really thick
this was really thinks it was the
beginning of the book there's a it
engages far more of your brain then then
an e-reader and there's all these things
like even just the cover of the book all
becomes associated with the content in
the book so when you need to retrieve it
you can kind of remember any of those
things
because you people will even say I
remember where on the page it was was
like in the upper left hand corner of
the page or whatever these are all keyed
into how your memory works not
there's a way that I understand how
memory works that I don't know if it
corresponds to what science currently
his present or has shown but it's kind
of what I've synthesized out of all the
different self-help things that that
I've learned but basically I believe you
memory I believe that when you remember
something what you actually remember is
everything that was going on in your
body and your mind at that moment so you
remember the background sounds you
remember the the color of the walls all
of that is in there and that's how your
brain keeps it separate because it
remembers the stuff that you the stuff
that you wrote in your notebook taking
notes the day that you wore the blue
pants is a separate memory from the
stuff you wrote in your notes the day
you wore the red pants and you're not
consciously aware of that but your brain
actually I mean that's part of how your
brain tells those two memories apart and
if everything is the same the more
that's the same the harder it is for
your brain to retrieve the information
so on a physical book different physical
books are different they're different
sizes the different page layouts
different fonts etc but it's consistent
within that book so all of those things
become associated at some level with
that book and again this is my theory as
to why this is the case with an e-book
every single thing is either variable or
the same as all the others every single
book you read is is the same frame the
same thickness in fact with the Kindle
at least the with the the Kindle app I
don't I've never used a physical Kindle
you scroll so it's the same information
isn't even at the same place on the
screen each time and you might change
the font in which case now everything is
all scrambled from where it was the last
time you looked at it so even when
you're watching a YouTube video that the
YouTube video is always on a
two-dimensional flat surface and that
there's never any additional senses that
help you with understanding the
information they're augmented it's never
like now pause the video and go and
actually perform this activity in the
physical world where you engage your
sense of eyesight and smell and touch
taste and that way you can better retain
the information right you know it's
retention it's even thinking ability I
mean we think with more than just our
like abstract thought like like I think
they've shown that that your entire body
can be involved in in the way you store
and access information this is probably
actually great for the show too for Pete
to try as the speaker that we're
featuring is teaching things to pause
and to reflect and engage on the
knowledge that is actually being taught
something else I I don't know if this
works on video so one of the things they
have shown is that when two people are
talking face-to-face they are engaged in
theirs what I'll call kind of big chunk
mirroring right like you nod your head I
nod my head those are very big big
mirroring chunks I've also read some
research that says that people are
engaged in very very rapid like faster
than can be consciously detected micro
movements and things I don't know if
that's and I wish I could remember the
source of the research but basically
that when you're face to face with
someone you're actually engaging on more
levels and faster with a feedback
mechanism then you can even do a for
video because there's a time lag with
video and with things like Skype you
have to look at the camera if you want
them to see you making eye contact but
then you're not looking at them it's
actually different and it's not the way
your brain is wired to understand it do
you know the about the multitasking
research by the way new teachers the
well basically multitasking turns our
brain to mush well one thing that one
can say about doing this thing of this
task switching is that there's a there's
an opportunity cost there's a switching
cost there's when you focus on one thing
at a time you really get to dive deeper
firewires focus when you switch between
it takes you a piece of time to be able
to really kind of get into a flow state
of doing that other tasks but this is
even different from that this is
actually just trying to do multiple
things at once like be on your phone
while you're carrying on a conversation
not only not only can you not do it at
any level of quality but it actually
degrades your ability to think it
actually makes a bit shortened to her
attention span
at Stanford this was a few years ago you
can just google Stanford multitasking
what they found was they were asking the
question do people raised in
multitasking do they develop the
cognitive ability to do that and the
answer was no in fact they are degraded
just as much as if people who weren't
raised that way so multitasking doesn't
work
sad but true we have so much more to
unpack about all of these things and
there's just a lot of wisdom that
you've accumulated in your life that I'm
just I'm so grateful that we're able to
sit down and talk about it now and when
we do round two we're just gonna be able
to jump deeper and deeper into all the
nuance here and hopefully have more and
more items for people to embody and
practice yeah a couple quick questions
on the way out Steve our first question
is what is a skill that you think every
child should know going into the
exponential technology age how to
identify and challenge your limiting
beliefs beautiful and succinct I love
that are we in a simulation no no we're
not I'll ask you more about why next
time sure what's the most beautiful
thing in the world community and a
functioning ecosystem and planet stiver
thank you so much for joining us on the
show greatly appreciate it thank you for
having you thank you thanks everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate you'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below check out Stevie's links
below as well go and share more thoughts
like this around the world with our
co-workers our friends our families
online go and have more conversations
about calm what we talked about with
stiver today and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world thank you so much for tuning in
and we will see you soon see you soon
peace